前髪が気になるなぁ　誰も見てねぇだろうな
こんにちは‼　はじめしゃちょーです
あっ‼誰か見てるな？
あぁ、えっと今日はですね。ちょっとね副音声なんで
音が録れてなくて、今日は副音声でお楽しみください
こちら　のびのびエキスパンダーという
筋トレグッズです。ゴムで出来てる
俺は思った。
この筋トレグッズを使ってですね
バンジージャンプができるんじゃないかって
この橋の下で
俺はですね、バンジージャンプをしたかったんですよ
簡単にね‼
・・・・・・
やってみたかったんすよ‼
でね！今日はね
この柔らかい、ソフトタイプの
えっと
のびのびバウンダー
それをたくさん買って、くっつけました
そしてこやって背中にせおってね
この状態でここ（橋）から
バンジージャンプをしたら
ひょっとしたらビョーンってフッてなって浮けるんじゃないか
ソフトって書いてあるからね
柔らかい感じでですね
やってみたいと思ってるんすよ　実際に
では早速やってみましょう‼
ok　このストレッチバンドゥーを
ここに装着して
そのまま飛び込みます
ここにくくりつけます
橋に付いてるこのバンドと僕をくっつけて
ダイブしてきます
はい、こんな感じです
おっしゃー！！
準備は出来たぞー！
いいか！！
いきます！！
あっあっあっはぁっ⤴（震え声）
ちょっとｗ　思ったより怖いんだけど
えっ、こわいよっ
助けてー
いきます
では筋トレグッズを使ったバンジージャンプ
やってみましょう
水に着水する前に
ふわっと浮きます
間違いないです
えっ、まってこれさ、えっ
跳ね返って頭打たないよね？
いきます！
えっ、まって
マジやべぇ
大丈夫だよね？
ほんとに怖いんだけど
いきます
ハッハッハハ（友達の笑い）
ハサミない？
あっーー痛った！！
やばい、やばい、まってまって
あれは実に失敗だったね
やっぱりソフトは柔らかいからダメなんだね
ていうことで今回はこちら
ハードを準備しました
今度はこのハードタイプで実際に…
あの…
あれです…
えっと…
あの…
そこからこう(橋からジャンプ)ね
ブワンと！
バンジ(噛んだ)
これで行こう！
これで行きます
これで足りるっしょ
足りすぎるんじゃないっすか？(撮影者)
これで？
え、でもこんなんだよ？(はじめ)
行けるかな？
じゃあこれでやりましょう！
ハアハア…(恐怖)
行きます！
ふざけんなよ…(小声)
楽しくないから
ダメだね
ダメですね(撮影者)
非常に(ゴム切れる)痛てっ
行きます